the appalachian region of eastern
kentucky is under water several days of
rainfall have caused rivers to overflow
their banks and entire towns to barely
remain above water lines
the area got two months worth of
rainfall in the matter of just two days
with recovery and rescue efforts ongoing
in some areas the flood waters have not
even crested yet
for those residents who did survive the
storm they told stories of horror
everything's going like
everything is gone
the whole life is gone
i was like i don't want this apartment
to buckle with me in it so
i just kind of was like i'd rather be in
the woods than
be inside the apartment
the flash flooding is so severe even
rescuers were shocked by what they were
dealing with probably 95 of the people
in this area here's lost everything
houses cars
animals
it's
it's heartbreaking it really is
these four siblings were all swept away
in the floodwaters
they drowned and their bodies have all
been recovered
the governor who declared a state of
emergency on friday toured the
hardest-hit areas
elsewhere in america overnight monsoon
rains in las vegas flood waters seen
coming through the roof of at least one
of the city's famous casinos
there was also flooding in west virginia
and hundreds were rescued from flood
waters in missouri
while parts of america are soaking wet
other parts are melting
it all comes after the northeast of the
u.s saw unseasonably and dangerous
record high heat earlier this month and
meteorologists know what's causing it
these type of events that have been
occurring over the last couple of weeks
across the country are directly
attributable to climate change
these are big signals extreme heat heavy
downpours
that harken back to the changes in our
atmosphere because of the additional
carbon because of the warming
in kentucky cleanup will mostly have to
wait because they're still in the search
and rescue phase of this storm
officials say the death toll is likely
to climb
gabriel lozando al jazeera